tell me who has given you the biggest
assist off the court coach manty I think
just him being in my life helped me grow
just as a human I appreciate him so much
just how he is as a person you know it's
just beyond just coaching you feel like
you're one of his kids you know like he
just feel like he adopts you you miss
him on assignment look at the bench and
he's just like staring at you like like
a mad you know
like there's times where like you're
struggling in basketball and like he
kind of lets that off your shoulders a
little bit you know it's bigger than
baskball basketball even when you do
struggle especially when I was in
Phoenix when I was struggling games if
I'm struggling I'm mad at myself cuz I'm
not helping my team out and I'll come in
the next day or something and M is like
happy and it kind of makes me relax like
kale calm down like happens like
you had a bad game you had a bad game
like we move we move so like him giving
that confidence to me where I walk in
like you know what like it's bigger than
basketball
sometimes